[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
plätzchen rezept also petting film
eigentlich schon sagen kleines
weihnachts und winter gepäck und zwar
werde ich rächen machen
die zentren sind wirklich super einfach
in der herstellung ihr müsst aber ein
paar tipps von wir beachten damit sie
wirklich super einfach auch gelingen ihr
braucht dafür kein besonderes werkzeug
wo ich mal kann ich dafür noch
schokolade aber egal und sie schmecken
wirklich super lecker hier habe ich die
variante einmal die zentren und dann
habe ich sie noch in kuba töre getaucht
und den weiße schokolade als ich finde
es wirklich schön und du cool aus und
vor allem sind sie richtig knusprig und
ihr braucht dafür nur ganz ganz wenige
zutaten und die zeige ich euch mal da
vorne für dezent waffeln brauche ich
drei eiweiß eine prise salz 100 gramm
puderzucker 60 g weiche butter 75 gramm
mehl einen teelöffel zimt und einen
esslöffel sahne zuerst einmal nehme ich
jetzt das eiweiß und es kommen jetzt in
eine saubere und fettfreie schüsse
da gebe ich das salz mit dazu das
zerstört die eiweißstrukturen ein
bisschen schneller und dadurch wird der
schnee auch schneller fest und jetzt
kann ich das eiweiß es noch schlagen
sobald der schnee fest kommt es noch die
hälfte des puderzucker es mit dazu und
wird schön eingerührt und dann nehmen
wir den runter nehmt eine separate hilfe
und da kommt jetzt die butter rein
gemeinsam mit den übrigen puderzucker
und vanille extrakt sich ja fast
vergessenen vom autor zimt und jetzt
kann ich die zutaten für etwa zwei bis
drei minuten cremig verrühren
das war ja nie was geworden ohne vanille
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier das mehl dazugeben
und natürlich auch die wichtigste zutat
nach an den lecks fragt zimt und etwas
sahne und jetzt werden die zutaten noch
ganz kurz ein gerührt an der stelle gebe
ich jetzt noch ein bisschen schnee
gezogen
den restlichen einschnitt den habe ich
jetzt einfach mit einem schneebesen
unter
wenn jetzt könnt ihr entweder mit einem
esslöffel oder mit einem ganz kleinen
eisbär kleine häufchen aufs backblech
setzen und diese dann mit einer palette
oder mit einem messer dürfe streichen
und so groß wie jetzt macht so groß
werden auch später die röllchen das
heißt wenn ihr sie zu breit macht
weidenröschen sei lang wenn es ein
bisschen schneller macht werden sie
dementsprechend kurz
[Musik]
so und so kommen sie jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze da brauchen sie nur drei bis
vier minuten beim ersten blech
kontrolliere ich immer ob sie schön
braun am rand werden und da muss ich sie
wirklich sofort raus holen die sie
nämlich einfach so dünn dass wir
wirklich sehr schnell verbrennen
so jetzt sind die rollen fertig und ihr
müsst sie jetzt auch sofort weiter
verarbeiten das heißt ich nehme jetzt
eine palette und je einmal ganz
vorsichtig unter den teig jetzt könnt
ihr die kontrollen aufhören und so
können sie dann erkalten mädels nicht
sofort macht an kühlen sie ab und werden
einfach sofort knusprig und dann lassen
sie sich eben gar nicht mehr aufholen
ihr könnt jetzt entweder so in sich
zusammenrollen oder ihr nehmen zum
beispiel einen kochlöffel oder so wie
hier so ein schaum rollt ihr könnt es
vorher kurz ein spiel mit back trend
spray und dann darauf auf rollen und
dann kann man die zentralen sogar noch
mit einer sahne creme oder so befüllen
und ich mache jetzt immer nur vier stück
auf einem blech weil ich einfach nicht
so schnell werden dass sich sechs auf
einmal rollen kann also vier sind am
besten so bleiben sie schön heiß und bei
mir waren es jetzt etwa dreieinhalb
minuten im ofen
jetzt sind die zentralen abgekühlt und
ihr könnt jetzt entweder so lassen oder
noch weiter dekorieren so wie ich das
machen werde
ich habe zar peter kober türe bereits
erwärmt und zwar habe ich zwei drittel
davon einfach über dem warmen wasserbad
erwärmt dann herunter gezogen und dann
das restliche drittel eingerührt mit
etwas kokosfett und so wird sie eben
schon glänzend und jetzt könnt ihr die
kuvertüre auch ebenso ein kleines
schnaps gläschen oder in kleinen
messbecher einfüllen und dann die
zentralen eindruck
soweit wir gerne möchte und dann auf dem
abkühlen gitter abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann auch ein bisschen
weiße kuvertüre in einen gefrierbeutel 5
und da noch ein bisschen drüber fließen
lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt lasse ich die röllchen fest
werden und dann kann ich sie bereist
servieren moralisch zu probieren
ulla unbedingt um ihr denkmal
ich finde ohne schokolade schon richtig
gut aber vor allem welches mal selbst
gemacht also erst einmal zeit glauben
ich selbst gemacht ist gut dass die
weihnachtskugel nicht aus glas war sind
jetzt erst richtig knusprig war ja nicht
durch gewalt gut gästen und zwar einfach
weil man hier wirklich abwandeln wie man
möchte also ich hab jetzt sind heutigen
gemacht ihr könnt auch an den reichen
machen tonkabohnen röllchen zitronen
rolston mit weißer krawatte fußball nach
orangen rollten hinaus richtig
weihnachtlich
aber ich finde gehen auf das ganze jahr
über also ich kenne auch die gekauft und
sind deutschland die habe ich früher
immer ganz gerne gegessen
und ja ich einfach mal richtig tun was
richtig cooles einfaches falls ihr auch
diese sind solche nachmachen möchte dann
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei aufs
tennis - blog.de
da steht es noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim zubereiten
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
bis danzig capella bringt die ganze
weihnachtsdeko durch den sich basel i
brauch wieder auf
[Musik]